thank you to better help and Shopify
for sponsoring more on them after the
reaction reject Nation we're going to watch what
I can only imagine to be the greatest movie ever
made The Beekeeper I'm of course joined by the
man I've been covering all these action movies
with Andrew Gordon Andrew how are you I'm doing
great Greg but I want to know who's impression
is better it's definitely mine but what's most
important are we watching the theatrical cut
or the air cut we watching whatever cut regardless
it's going to be the greatest movie ever made some
people say we sound Australian I don't hear it I
think these are the greatest Impressions you're
ever going to hear of Jason STM on this YouTube
platform anyway guys did you see The Beekeeper
Andre and I've been so excited to watch this
I think we're we're Jazz we're jacked up all
righty Andrew you ready to do it let's do it
leave a like also be sure to subscribe click
that notification Bell to get notified whenever we
got a reaction up on this channel thanks to prea
for helping us set it down these highlights also
massive thank you to all who have joined us at
our patreon page becoming super sexy re IM I kept
this up you going to say how long can you do this
I'm impressed F Tri the Fang Reaction watch along
we syn up with the own copy of beekeeper John and
I also cover several shows over there exclusively
with highlights and watch alongs included let's do
it I'm the line Tamer I hope that's
his next movie she just going to
battle every every kind of animal
that exist and I would pay to see
it that should be his his stick it
should be his uh typ casting Bing
kangaroo oh you see the the letters
they're like like Stingers oh that's
neat there's autistic Merit to
this it's very stylized thank you
David hair oh my God there's
a whole history to unpack of
beekeepers it's really neat oh I didn't know
Josh erson was in this H forg thought he
was love this this is going to be like
a secret organization that has spanned
centuries it looks like true historical Protection
Program Jason STM was a producer on
this I'm the producer I'm the [Laughter]
producer ominous it's a good
establishing shot to show it's a shadowy
organization that's a cool mood kind of reminds me
to the town from first bej juice reference number
one those things scare me to death then killing
my honeybees few days unchecked Wipe Out the whole
Colony what are you going to do with them well
that's between me and them if you don't mind what
does that mean he's going to torture them they're
putting up with me and all of my bees this place
is crab grass and weeds and you brought it back
to life no one's ever taken care of me before
bees are an endangered species yeah unfortunately
Mr Clay come back at supper time let me feed you
don't bring the bees with you he put like trackers
in the bees or is he just an actual beekeeper oh
oh my God whoa I've never seen that done before
interesting method damn that is beautiful did
you know Jason Stam uh studied beekeeping for six
months prior to doing this I made that [__] up
I'm a method actor no who did that now Jason
STM is going to seek retribution I like how
uh that's all draped in yellow like bee color
United data group good afternoon this is void
how may I help you oh I hate this guy already oh
hello I I just got a message saying that there's
a problem with my computer why are you calling
the number the message you received is from our
United data group antivirus software it's part
of the software package that you pre-installed
on your computer oh I'm sorry I'm not a computer
person what did you say the name of your product
is again uh she seems like such a sweet old lady
I know that's who they Prey Upon the most is older
people there is actually a software package that
you can download that would allow me to resinall
remotely oh my gosh what a jerk can you uh can
you type this friendly friend. net spell just how
it sounds I'm there oh this seems like a realistic
con artist prick oh of for sure yeah I clicked the
button so you're about to see some windows open
closed on your desktop as I reinstall the vir
shield for you wow I hope you clowns are paying
attention you stick to the script you are not
Leo DiCaprio and I choose Rich every time she has
got 10K checking life insurance annuity Roth IRA
teachers pension and that is so messed up [__]
[__] all right she is a signatory wow let the
scrip mining begin oh my God that is actually
infuriating just because of I want to punch
through the screen right now can you log into
that account and verify the transfer please Miss
Parker hold on yes there's she's so innocent this
a transfer for $50,000 I made a terrible mistake
I was supposed to credit you $500 but I know I
got a a stuck key here I'm going to lose my job
here no I could wire the amount back I will need
a different password though one second now this
is the master password for all her accounts we get
it we zero out everything a yuck I think I should
call the bank please don't you're probably right
but there goes my job and there goes all your
data oh she a widow yeah and I'm assuming this
is she's going to want to take her own life after
this [Music]
hello wow the worst of the worst douche piece
of crap uh oh oh God whoa was not expecting a
feel this much not going to lie Dam this is real
this feels so which he's going through right now
[__] oh my God these are uncomfortable
Goosebumps I'm getting that
is awful a this poor poor
woman honey looks delicious
though oh I'm so scared she's
not going to be okay smart cuz
even if this move movie gets like cheesy
action fun starting off on a serious note
is really good do you need that
opposition good direction David
a oh man don't you move oh oh [__] drop
the knife she the one from
Umbrella Academy I think she
is now who the why would you suspect this
the one who came in here at calling her name
Verona ah I'm so sorry well how do you know
my yikes though we can clear him me our best
and only per clear him damn lens flares on the
camera this is really starting a heavy note let's
just completely ignore the big white dude in her
house with a knife get him up surprisingly
effective because the the communication he
had with her was was limited but you could
feel it through the emotion and the tone I
was bringing her a jar of honey who the are
you Winnie the Pooh the keep bees how do you
know my mother R some space in the bomb from
her have a sign leas she didn't answer when
I knocked I noted a car in the driveway I
had the smoke alarm and I entered you got a
law enforcement background I told you I'd take
care of bees most badass beekeeper I am so on
boarded from taking out all those guys guys
I was not expecting to beat this personally
invested you see on the phone all the fraud
alerts and all that [__] there there you
go I'm surprised it still stayed logged in that
long when I usually get booted out in like 5 10
minutes it's the most unrealistic part of this
movie undoubtedly nothing more unrealistic is
to come his hands test a negative for gunshot
residue but the prince on the gun were your
mothers yep I wanted to thank you for taking
care of my mom tried to stay in her life as
much as I could obviously I could have done a
better job being old can be a lonely thing the
certain age you used to exist used to be a part
of life or the family or of the hive I guess you
could say you know I think I know why she liked
you you're just like my brother he was in marso
a marine Raider he was killed a few years ago
kicking doors his family's experienced a lot
of tragedy she got scammed somebody emptied out
all her accounts she was an educator director of
a charity for kids I got 2 million out of that
account know it did it there's some commentary
here I talked to an agent in our cyber crimes
office this crew's been operating for 2 years
and we don't even have names jeez you don't need
a cyber security team you need a beekeeper taking
from an elderly person is as bad as stealing from
a child maybe worse why have we been stealing from
children this whole time Andrew the money's in
the elderly yeah and so help me God I'm going to
get these mother who did this like how it's like
the the yellow with the Angelic light cuz he is
the Angel savior what are you doing I thought you
retired I did I need a favor oh he's got a past a
name and address easy this is exting not easy
know even the FBI can't find these people well
we're not the FBI are we should me the DS and
standby they're routing all over the world you
found them sure but who these people you want to
find out is that this a good the ramp up this it's
actually more patient than I expected who the hell
you think you're going pal this United data group
this is private property and you're trespassing
I'm going inside this is a I'm going to burn it
down you're not going anying where
except write the back the way you
came shut up do you know what they do
here buddy I'm count of three seal from
the elderly one two three there I did it
for you so badass scamming the weakest in
our society stealing everything they
have do you know that's who you work
for yes oh [__] that is what I'm talking
about but it's emotional action protect
the old tell any of the companies in
the building to evacuate now there's
going to be a fire okay thanks need your
attention please repeat after me I will
never steal from the weak the vulnerable
[Laughter] again he's here to bring
order sh repeat after me I will never
steal from the weak and the vulnerable
again I will never steal here to teach you
a lesson kids I hope anyone who actually
does this is watch watching this movie
and thinks twice about [Music] that wow
he's the psycho you're the cold-hearted
sons of [__] what the you think you're
doing I'm a beekeeper to protect the hive
this is a multi-million dollar operation
[__] okay so you can't come up here white
nighting [__] will you stomp his ass out
please
yes yes yeah yeah oh my God I love it
yes it's like J Jason Bor me Jackie
Chan damn that was
awesome but you feel really proud of yourself
I've never seen that he slammed right onto the
keyboard that was great I was not expecting
him to get here so quickly I mean there's a
problem you got to solve it man the next
call from your little fishing scam to
this call center will make a spark across
these wires anything alive in here won't
be I'm liking this more that
I already knew I would like
it yeah from the trailers I was not expecting
to I thought it just G to be a non action piece
I thought it just be like yeah I just want to
watch a goofy goofy goofy film yeah it it came
back the whole thing yeah and it's it's like I
can barely it's all tweaked oh those are nice
mhm Josh Hutcherson is playing a douchebag Three
Amigos skateboard it's fake ass hippie [__]
he must be from Southern California this dude
just scolls in see we're stealing from people
and and he burns the place to the ground
four people didn't get out you're telling
me that this [__] burnt the entire building
down and dropped fouring [Laughter] bodies hey
I need to talk to you Jeremy Irons if I had a
friend who like had a call center and someone
burned it down and maybe killed some people you
could get him right get him yeah like disappear
the problem come on you literally ran the CIA
and you're telling me you can't just find some
guy in Massachusetts listen this sounds like
a job for the police I know this guy's back
right now you're going to log into our cloud
and you're going to look at anyone connected
to the last few deals you closed what if I find
this guy you get a wrecking crew together and
you go good Fellas on I mean come on you're a
connected guy right you understand I understood
that reference he doesn't like to get his hands
physically dirty though you good yeah I'm great
why I mean you did lose your mother yesterday
thanks for the reminder remember United data
group you sober enough to drive where's mine it's
an old cup for my car with instant gas station
and hot water e no are they also like ex lovers
I think that's the application that's clown car
saw everything but no one's talking all frequent
flyers with Burgery fraud and cyber beeps I want
IDs on all of them you know this is just a tip
of like 20 Spears right can I just have this
moment back to business as usual so in
this beekeeper program you retire and
remain a beekeeper what do the bees actually
do okay Widow just has a daughter in Boston
I don't think this is it but Matt Pat
you are making a terrible call that's
him oh he knows he knows what are
you guys supposed to do to him oh
no oh my God he knew they'd be coming
yeah ke was talking about him I guess
he's a bee Lover he breaks my [__] you
break his [__] that's why I said oh no
[Music]
God oh my goodness what are we in
for dark yellow lighting now oh
you guys just stroll into the wrong
place oh all that honey I feel like
this is going to be fun this going be a fun
gory time let's go hiding [__] come face
us I bit
now such a worm it's like
Batman beekeeper
begins do
it oh I mean that is like Batman
a silent takedown I know very
methodical not
even that was
nasty
oh oh
[Music] boy where are you
here help me is he going to get the eyeball one
now we we we can talk about this we we can talk
about this this just worked this out me and you
we can f yes a why didn't you just listen to him
oh my [Music] God the action in here is so well
done oh it's fantastic it's really well done why
are people just wiring you their entire life
savings must be your winning personality they
got us a lawyer so maybe you want to talk to
them you know this is a really nice shirt by
the way did you steal it out of a caset you dog
are you applauding people who sleep with dogs I'm
applauding her line oh I agree with her oh my
bad I misunderstood oh so you like fires yeah
today I do good cuz uh today's your lucky day cuz
apparently your mother's house is on fire too and
some other [__] This Woman's dealing with a
lot of what a coldhearted way of delivering that
information United dat grou well he's handsome
you think there's even the remotest chance that
the dude who burned down United data group is
the same guy we entering the spot from your
mother The Beekeeper said the name of the title
this movie is taking itself just serious enough
you know what I mean yeah to like it's actually
a really fascinating tone they're writing and it
because you you want the action to feel like
th Artic when it's happening instead of just
hurry up and get to it it's fun who who the is
he tell me who he is right now I I I I don't know
beekeeper what's he saying about
bees I don't know he said he was
protecting the hive or something
he in the back of the car there he
is oh he wanted him to make that call I I got
NF what no is this man what is he doing is he
going to drag him with the car or you're
[__] crazy man what the [__] bro oh is
he going to drag him uh I feel like it worse
than that man that's pretty bad drag is still
bad oh I think he's going to drive it off and
he's going to go I don't know let's just find
out yeah cuz isn't the Bridge open yeah oh
God cool well technically a drag do I have
the pleasure of speaking with yes you burned
up a million dollar call center now I'm going
to burn you down you haven't told me your name
you Mr you and you bettering remember it [Music]
you sound young I bet you don't
have estate planning I'm I'm 28
years old why would I need that I'm about to show
you 80s action dialogue and this is your data
mining consumer service business right yeah
something like that pulling in 9 million
a month one office I've got like 20 if a
beekeeper says you're going to die you're going
to die there's nothing I can do or or anybody
else to stop it oh cuzz he's a CIA he knows
who he is yeah I could have done anything but
I chose this job as a favor to your mother I
keep danth Enterprises safe is his stepfather
Wallace just tell me what the this guy is he's
probably the last pair of eyes that you're
going to sneer at that is daunting it's like
Jeremy Irons wants his stepson to die what'd
you get on Clay he's a ghost all I have is a
birth certificate as social never even had a
bank account why does this guy seem so goddamn
apathetic towards everything Adam clay doesn't
exist which is terrifying to me because he's
probably in a classified program if we don't
get a beekeeper Cinematic Universe I will Riot
wasted opportunity I'll give you a board seat
on the holding company that's another million
a year plus you promised you'd take care of
him you have my word oh he really loves
her my young friend seems to have caught
the unwanted attentions of of a beekeeper
a beekeeper beekeeper well that's not good
[Music] dark yellow yellow is the theme color
in this film he's retired from the program no
longer active well that Chang I like the reversal
on this framing now he's handheld and she's Center
framed in the camera still the current active
beekeeper lunatic should have been removed months
ago almost feels like the Continental
little with like uh with tech that's
upgrade but like lower crate I hear
like fax machines and old monitors and
stuff got my job honey
uh-oh get out of here oh yes yes you
need colorful personality bag guys let's
go oh uh what are you going to do
oh you've been a busy bee kill
her I'm assuming you're my
replacement
ouch
God the action so
good ouch Jesus he really is Batman
oh wow wow damn this this turned
into a whole kind of different
action movies oh Jesus L her up
what a burn he still has not fired one shot in
this film really that is impressive good catch
Andrew okay so he takes the fingers and I have
no idea why did you it's like dude you're sure
no problem badass work I'm a fan me that
can set the whole G yeah man did he tell
that guy that's civilian to leave to I hope
so he doesn't seem like an evil human being
that's a vehicle registered to a anet landroid
everywhere he goes it ends up in Flames that's
a minigun they use those on military vehicles
do you know that puppy shoot 6,000 rounds a
minute I do think all this like FBI [__] could
use a lot more personality though you know it's
one part of the storytelling that I feel like
lacks okay then do you know who Anna at landas
is yes I do I think it's more him even so who
doesn't exist in any commercial or government
database someone who a ghost like our good
friend Adam clay beekeeping for beekeepers
I think she does a really good job though yeah I
like her she's really good how are you my friend
good come on leave him alone leave him alone
don't play with those things they go off oh my
god look this is where all the diversity is
and the stuntmen they got to play key roles
for the action now Simon Says beekeepers
have given all resources empowered to act
on their own judgment for decades they have
quietly worked to keep the hive safe damn
I am the law beekeepers keep working until
they die he's basically one of us he's not
like you got to pull the stinger out with
enough of you then maybe you just might in
fact be able to kill him I like how they've
constructed everything around being actual
beekeeping oh okay smart I thought beekeepers
weren't supposed to intervene and
why does that beekeeper behave so
sadistically he's getting the location of
every single one he's going to take them
all down we believe that Mr Clay is connected
to a classified program named beekeeper let's
stick to what we know [__] she totally seems
like she knows this is his next Target nin star
United which appears to be the entity operating
the regional call centers like the one that Mr
Clay burned down why is Adam Clay on this Rampage
tell him avenging my mother what's your ask my ask
a swap team for starters surveillance support
additional agents analysts that shouldn't be
a problem do she want to stop him didn't I mean
she wants to uncover the truth yeah she doesn't
know exactly like what any connections are and
stuff Phoenix where we at oh my God 201k 200k I
love you how can you live with yourself doing
this crap every Target on there was an older
person out awful all weapons on Entry We Ready
give me an o o power down the private security
here under orders of the Governor State Department
certified oh is that one of the Jeremy iron's Crew
He was the main guy yeah the main guy who spoke
up you're not welcome here get the out all right
boys let's go set up the per outside it's yellow
in the background closed and locked steel gate
want a body on comms watch delivery dog same
deal we don't see Jason stay them a lot it's
kind of interesting instead of going in Smoke
them out I figured I'd give the five Fighters
a break I put him through enough already what do
you say your mean was currently I go by Adam clay
there was a back entrance I would have used it I
don't want to injure anyone who's innocent or not
involved he's such a bad ass somebody detain
this guy oh nobody he won't kill any of them
wa damn oh D he is [__] oh my God why you
my business CU Mr west wild hire me to kick
some beekeeper ass Mr west wild works
for me which means that you work for
me now listen that place is the crown
jewel of my kingdom they didn't have
you so maybe you just do your job and and
don't tell me how to do mine please copy
that set up a perimeter outside let's go
move letting his ego get the best of him
Greg I love how he lets the
buildup it's just yes yeah we love
you stab him with the pen oh he just let
them clear us so funny not a good day to
dve some people into this these [__] Not
Innocent for either one of us to close that
distance some of them will get hurt let's
start with this right here ouch [Music]
ouch wonder if they're going to go
all film without him shooting a gun
so does Jason S and view these guys as
innocent they seem like they're working
for the wrong people yeah but this would be
self-defense still but he's is very clear on
not hurting on not killing innocent
people yeah but if you work for the
villains y he doesn't be the best innocent
okay fire oh good cool lighting
fire clean sweep you know who you're working for I
business I'm just the guy they call when there's a
problem you're creating a bigger problem man
and you are a problem God damn right I'm a
problem [Music]
oh ouch that would kill a man
if not break every bone in his
face
oh he going to drop the
elevator oh
no
oh oh [__] please please don't kill
me I'm just the middle manager I never
Hur nobody shut up I'd respect you more if
you look people in their eyes when you stu
from now you're making a lot of
money here what are you about to
do I know you're the middle man who's
above you they'll kill me what do you
think he's going to do I'll torture you then kill
you such a cool torture scene interrogation T it's
so simple like the stapler of a
damn make it stop you can make it
stop dedicated her whole life to helping people
yesterday she shot herself she took 2 million
from a cherry she ran she was the only person
who ever took care of me it's like losing a
mom these people they're Untouchable no
please please I stop I I will I will let
me sure you better not do some stupid move
I told you they were Untouchable nobody's
un touchable sometimes when the hive is out
of balance you have to replace the queen I
love all these yeah Clay that man is directly
responsible for your mother's death I believe
you but we have laws for these things I can't
put my personal life in front of my jaws you
have laws for these things until they fail then
you have me yes the laws are protecting these
things oh no not Mr Personality I
have four kids three boys and a girl
what man does his research okay I guess he's
not bad yeah he would have uncovered that
yeah [Music] colors holy [__] what's his name
that's a son of a important politician oh right
right right maybe now's the time to call your
mother he can't make his move on us if we're
in her proximity can he I still don't see that
stopping him you're scared and you want to use my
mother as a human shield just call her just call
her come on I'm actually was going to you know get
together with some of my tech homies and stuff
if that's uh that's cool with you is she podus
no way is she oh she is oh she is God are you what
a reveal I just figured she was a Senator or a I
felt like cuz someone mentioned about meeting with
pus or something earlier and I was like is she pus
yeah why not let clay do his thing your mom is
dead because of these people like Boondock Saints
I haven't seen it put it on the list okay we think
we have a sense of Mr Clay's true intentions he
seems to be following the money looks so much
slower on that camera nin star United uses
data mining software to identify these people and
then Target their assets there's another involved
are you going to tell me the name of this Company
Danforth Enterprises with an annual revenue of 10
billion dollar founded and operated by Jessica
Danforth who recently stepped down because she
was sworn in as president of the United States
who else knows this us three Let's uh keep the
circle small that's dangerous information to have
about the president of the United States I see his
kill count is steadily rising in a beehive there
is something called a queen Slayer it's a bee that
will rise up and kill the queen if she produces
defective Offspring oh my God clay believes that
Derek Danforth is the defective offspring of a
queen thereby clay will strike at the heart of
the problem and become a queen Slayer Adam Clay's
next victim is Derek Dan for's mother oh my God
you have a blank check good luck oh this isn't
insane I would not do that information on a zoom
call or whatever the hell they I would have th%
done that in person go away Federal Bureau of
something or another we're good all right you'll
need to excuse my partner he's recently concussed
hasn't slept in 2 days we're on the access list
good boss n that's been his personality the whole
movie the whole movie interesting choice they
picked for that is what it is but the screen time
they give Jason STM just seems so reserved doesn't
it yeah like you can go like a extended periods
without seeing him mom's detail is not going to
like that well if Mom's detail gets in the way of
what's coming for us they're dead men and so are
we tell them they can stay in the kitchen damn
they call this a state the beach house wasn't your
super secret CIA data mining software supposed to
I don't know maybe filter out Unstoppable killing
Mach don't you with me young man peeper yeah you
know I killed one once really yeah only cuz I was
lucky and un lucky my team will be out shortly if
anyone can knock this guys in the dirt it's them
thought that guy look like Steven Tyler little
tell that guy to hurry up I want every man
on this street welded shut this is David A's
Twitter the president is the ultimate B gu
oh I miss his I missed the hat out now he
just looks like Jason STM in every Jason STM
movie well at least they had it as long as we
[Music]
did it's at a Three Amigos
skateboard whoa I'm in there
now
oh I was late to picking up that he was wearing
their outfit although how much cooler would it
have been if he was wearing what he's been
wearing this whole time and then switching
into that guy's clothes why does Wallace westw
wild look nervous as a burning cat what have you
done to the man I wouldn't know mother well he's
there to protect you if you'll let him want to
go run the Free World don't burn it down don't
worry The Beekeeper coming to do that [__]
Love David A's like colorful choice of villainous
personalities he's like super Larger than
Life eccentric random characters that show
up no oh
okay just coming out and playing tight the
deputy director has flaged his uh concerns
about some uncomfortable things happening inside
the family company uncomfortable things about the
source of my campaign funds Mr Danforth are you
familiar with uh United data Group Place stupid
I invested in that how about a Nine Star unit
that's more of like a Consulting type role this
the blockchain issues and you bye dude this guy's
going to get killed at least we know he's not
rupt he just nods he's here St Targets in the
building East Wing give me everything you got
he's in the house how did he get by us we're
useless put your hands up now turn the around
is that is that him or no no how did he plan
for that he's outside Target's outside love
how he's always like 20 steps ahead of everyone
well Beast have an ability to anticipate man on
your knees on your knees place your fingers
behind your end down what's that in his hand
oh the the detonate the detonators for those
bombs he planted in the cars slide a hand
there St it behind you a [__] whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa I thought you stti back what
are you doing he's not even armed as long as Des
breathing his arms you're about to see something
amazing to be or not to be he isn't that the
bloody question I think will take to be to be
yeah oh shot damn oh my
God I really thought we were going on film
without a gunshot from him oh [__] H he's
alive oh it's he lives two weapons three
why are you waiting take it it easy take it
easy
whoa ouch
ouch oh oh excellent this guy's like
freaking 50 something R Jason you broke
the rules you corrupted an imperfect but
functioning system I was just trying to
get you into office Mom this is a good
conversation to have right now oh blame
blame you realize that you were behind
in 15 of 20 counties you needed to win
I taught CIA software to hunt money and
and not terrorists you didn't hear [Music]
that he has to like pick and choose who to kill
and who not and you got to elected because of
me and you know that now I know where the money
came from and all the people you hurt somebody in
this family has to have their [__] feet on the
ground to actually get [__] done you understand
that I like the transitioning Cuts back and forth
between the action and what are you going to do to
fix this calling the Army tell the truth really
that guy who's coming to kill us that beekeeper
I'm telling him the truth about what you did
Derek then I'm telling the entire nation and if
it costs me everything well so be it is he going
to kill his mom I think he's going to kill his mom
oh damn damn great shot nice Shoto cool
I love that POV from below that was
amazing oh great transition cut oh damn it's easy
The Mercenaries are obvious mercenaries come on
man oh I felt that might still be alive whoa we
haven't been doing our Jason
safe impression the entire
whoa
oh how is this guy still moving
oh wow bled him [Applause] up in
oh brutal
[Music]
effective sound design oh oh
god oh I love the brutality of this
oh he got one on him dude this guy
is tough as hell H I know he's Stu ferocious like
[Music]
[Applause] force I love how he studied that yes oh
[__] oh oh oh oh
how much more can you take he's hopping on one
leg Yeah that's right oh my God this is severed
arteries that was awesome that was a great fight
yeah that a great fight knuckle uppercut finish I
love it Jason say this performance there just just
the way like you would like take notes of a thing
it's a cool story to the way the fight was going
you're going to tell this guy the truth and hope
that he he spares you and kills me instead no d
I'll tell them the truth because it's the truth
oh they've been having the same dialogue for the
last like 10 minutes I'll tell the truth you going
to tell the truth I'll tell the truth beekeepers
live for the good of society I'm retired it's just
personal it's always been personal go back live
a quiet life I will when this is over that's all
I wanted my neighbor's dead but do you live in
the real world or just protect it what does it
matter to you how presidents come to be elected
what does matter right wrong it's not fashionable
it's an interesting climax with them don't do that
so you might want to step back no I don't want to
sorry I can't do that truth wait wait wait you
put that oh my God told you he was going to get
killed drop the weapon drop it wow
got interesting standoff here you
decide who you work for for the law
or for justice job more important
than your mother this Bye Mom oh full on
Cowboy shot he just straight up revolver
shot let him go and the bee just flew right by
him too it was sick can we confirm it was a be
it sounded like it your son was just about
to kill you still it's your son I know it's
true H yeah like a western he's amazing
then the sequel shall be fired you let
him go oh no uh what is he going to swim
back he's going to swim back he's the
swimmer and there he encounters a Megalodon yeah
right b no it's over quick transition we're done
I thought maybe she was going to announce to the
world uh how she got her Fortune what happened but
I guess we don't even need that that was that
was great thank you to Shopify for sponsoring
which is what we use for our merch store and is
our gamechanging partner in e-commerce you don't
need to be text have to understand it allows indiv
idual and businesses to create and manage online
stores offering tools for sales payments marketing
and inventory management it's worth trying out
because of its userfriendly interface extensive
customization options comprehensive Suite of
features that cater to businesses of all sizes
their checkout system unmatched it's 36% more
effective at converting visitors into buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget Shopify magic
the AI tool that elevates your business with
minimal effort but seriously reflecting on our
journey using Shopify for www. reation shop.com
it's been transformative the transition smooth
growth exponential thank you again reject Nation
from simplifying sales to scaling our offerings
Shopify has been a Cornerstone of our success
and Shopify isn't just for us owers 10% of us
e-commerce backing businesses big and small
and over 175 countries there are war-winning
support always there to guide you so ready to
join the revolution sign up for Shopify at only
a dollar a month at shopify.com reject all lcase
shopify.com reex start your Shopify success story
now let's grow together with Shopify team thank
you to better help for sponsoring this video I've
literally just finished a therapy session and
I wanted to shoot this cuz I'm in this state of
knowing why I Champion mental health support so
much in the past few weeks work's been a little
bit hectic it's led me to miss some sessions and I
really don't like doing that and sometimes that's
when the weight really starts to pile on a lot of
restless nights a lot of fatigue a lot of I can't
sleep even though I'm so tired sometimes just
a very deep-seated sense of Gloom meditating
and sometimes journaling are my daily go-tos
but sometimes they just just don't cut it when
I'm trying to pinpoint why I'm down and really
especially after a session like today therapy
just really helps clear the fog discussing the
feelings is a critical step for me especially as
someone who's diagnosed with ADHD type 2 bipolar
and PTSD it's truly a Cornerstone of my well-being
and I'm not alone in this many of us here at real
rejects are in therapy facing our own challenges
from depression to anxiety or just needing a
non-judgmental space to voice our thoughts this
year I've been working on most days of the week
to keep my physical health strong and I really do
Champion therapy as a way to strengthen my mental
resilience and for many better help is integral to
that process There's real value and better helps
accessible and adaptable service they match you
with the licensed therapist and provide the option
to switch if necessary ensuring the right fit for
your mental health Journey as this year winds down
and we confront life's complexities do consider
better help as a resource really happy to be
partnered with them this month so you can go
to betterhelp.com rejects for 10% off your first
month again that's bet t t r h lp.com slre rejects
so join us in moving forward stronger together
thank you again all righty well well thank you
so much to the sponsor of this video supporting
them helps support the channel so thank you guys
very much thank you Andrew for always wearing an
RR shirt man thank you to all been buying our real
re I wasn't planning Shing them out but I'm always
wearing them too you're the only other one you've
we them more than consistently more than John
we have so many shirts and getting one is also
a great way to support the channel really is great
involved ourselves and got two more in development
right now hopefully get a launch the first one
within the next week or so uh but yeah man listen
to us Apple Spotify we just watched The Beekeeper
Andrew beekeper The Beekeeper he's pretty quiet in
this one we've watched two movies of Jason sathan
where he was pretty subdued and quiet but again
you just always feel his presence and you and uh
like the way he's emoting his facial expressions
like it it didn't bother me that he had limited
dialogue I I I didn't care I loved him so much in
this movie but I loved how personal it was like
right away in the first like 10 15 minutes again
I I'd only experienced that one trailer that you
showed me after we watched Wrath of man I was like
this is going to be a schlocky fun little action
film I was not expecting it to be so heavy-handed
at least in the first 15 20 minutes and like
that is a real serious World thing where you
know people uh especially older people get
I mean obviously everyone deals with fraud
and scam uh you know artists and all that but it
really affects older people my unfortunately my
grandfather God Rest his soul he dealt with that
quite a bit um and we had to try and tell him many
times like no like you got to stop falling for
this and uh you know that that's a big audience
of who they go after so uh I like that David a
Incorporated that into the story and then that
was obviously the personal thing um also too I
really loved all the The Beekeeper stuff that
they were uh you know incorporating with all the
uh the lines in uh crap that I thought they were
very interestingly uh and well methodically used
used you know like just like the the queen beehive
and the offsp all that stuff it was just so well
utilized um and just like the organization and
the backstory and the history there was just
so many different interesting layers um but
again the the way everything was balanced out
from the action to the heavy-hearted and then
uh little incorporation of the humor as well uh
I thought very well done um I think like you uh
my only weak point was some of the the FBI stuff
uh especially more so on that one actor I'm sure
he's a great actor I haven't really seen him in
anything it's just I wasn't particularly fond
of the way the direction of that character was
used um personally and uh overall though uh this
was such a fun time um and such a heavy-hearted
subject again just with what happened with the
the one the old nice lady at the beginning you
know her offing herself um and what happened uh
just incorporating real life situations and then
the reveal to that she's the president I was not
expecting that I just figured just a regular
politician um just some interesting reveals and
uh also the hand toand combat oh my freaking God
I can't even imagine the level of difficulty that
all that planning took and the way uh you know
that um uh how long it took to film all of that
um and Jason STM he is the master that was like
very impressive to watch uh I got more to say but
what what did you think Craig uh I thought it was
a really fun movie I thought it was really fun and
in a way that I didn't anticipate being fun cuz
the trailers's pitched something that was going
to that I thought would just only lean into a
schlock Fest like you said like a cheese fest
of of an experience and while the cheesiness is
there yeah it it it's it's surprising like I think
in the first 15 20 minutes it was really smart to
lean into it being serious yeah because if you're
going to go onto this Mission this Vendetta
this Revenge Quest against this clandestine
organization you need to First ground it in
something that's not just Mission based you
need to ground in something that is like just
Primal which is Revenge but get you connected
to the characters at hand and you need want to and
the key to any Revenge movie is you have to want
to feel the character's motivation of getting that
Revenge it's a real I think revenge stories are a
very cathartic uh thing for people to experience
because in real life you know they say don't get
revenge that's bad most people shouldn't go after
getting revenge don't take the law your own hands
yeah yeah exactly but you know it's a fantasy a
lot of Us wish to live out and and so movies are
supposed to give us that cathartic experience
right of those feelings that releasee in a way
so I think investing you in that uh was smart and
and I feel like David a is a political commentary
side of you know uh politics and of course the
uh 1% systems in place corruption well was there
it it was all was a big part of the the World
building to it and there were times throughout
where I felt like maybe it was taking it I like
the first half I thought was actually near perfect
to me I think the first half was near perfect
in terms of the the the the tonal balance and
then the last half I thought kind of got a little
too like seriousness where I thought there was at
times I thought the self-awareness of what they
were doing might have been not as self-aware I
will say you know what I mean like it would just
get like super serious to the point where cuz this
movie has a weird um a weird approach where
you start off with Jason STM as his beekeeper
and while the movie revolves around him uh in all
fronts all aspects you'll you'll go these extended
periods of time where you're cutting around to
characters who are mainly just plot mechanics
like you got Jeremy Irons and Josh Hutcherson
interacting you got uh the the FBI people and
it feels like they lose sight of what should feel
more personal for the FBI uh girl aged uh I forget
I want to get her name cuz I believe she's the
one from Umbrella Academy yeah I think she is the
one from umbrella I want to get her name um yeah
like because and I felt like there was a lack of
wraparound for her when this started off as this
should also be something pretty per why does this
feel more personal for Jason St for her it was
her mom who died from this you know and and the
only reason I'm taking that serious is because
the movie started taking a more serious approach
but now I'm very selective on using the words but
and the words however because when they say but
that means you are negating everything that comes
before it I'm not negating it's a bit of a but and
a however however being in conjunction however
and but I would say that what I showed up for
was grandiose what I showed up for was awesome
like the action to me and the trailers didn't
even demonstrate uh what would make the because
to me whenever I see a Jason stapon trailer the
action looks the exact same like I feel like
it's the same choreographer and the same fight
scenes every time and while he always does a
great job that I look like the same [__] I've
seen in like every Jason STM movie and then
usually when you check into the film itself
you could see more of the uniqueness and to me
me because this is a hard R like we saw wrath
the man where there's no hand to hand right it
it's it's gun play gun sh and then here uh it's
it's mainly hand to hand for the guy with this
like Jason Bourne meets Jackie Chan s level of
violence where he use use brutality but you're
using props around you and the presence of Jason
STM of course like he's he he's that guy who can
play stoicism but ooze Charisma simultaneously
it's a gift it really he's got that it factor to
being a star and and I think he's excellent here
and the the violence was violent but but creative
yes and packed a punch and and I really loved uh
the and there was always a bit of a cathartic
release and and I like the sequences too when
he's when he's put in a position like at the uh
at the estate at the very end when he has to make
his way to the president you know he's got to
deal with mercenaries and SWAT team people and
SWAT team you don't kill mercenaries you can kill
and and so I like how in that action scene you're
like paying attention to if anything I think this
movie really proved David a is a hell of an action
director because because he has to get you like
follow the action follow follow this happening uh
in a sequence like that where normally you just
only get you don't kill these guys you only you
can harm them but you don't kill them and here
I like that that was a unique thing where I feel
like that can be overlooked it's a mix where
he's like okay you don't kill that guy but you
can kill this guy you know and he has to be like
anticipation anticipatory to that and the final
fight too like he saved a good brutal I thought
like the best fights might have been behind us
early on but he saved that brutal one-on-one
fight for that very end guy which was amazing
that fight yeah yeah so sometimes I thought like
this movie leaned into it cuz you know like you
got these like wacky colorful villains uh at times
The Mercenaries or or that other beekeeper lady at
the gas station where that's where I'm like okay
I feel like this movie is being self there are
times like the the the energy of the movie would
um lose itself lose some of the the like the The
Dread or drama wasn't strong enough to to Warrant
some of those scenes for me and then the fun would
get a little bit lost when you would cut to like
it was weird because Jeremy Irons podus lady and
and and and uh Josh Hutson they really gave like
performances here they did a really good job and
then the one who plays the FBI agent the FBI agent
uh it should be her right Emy raver lampin lampin
okay yeah and like she did a really good job too
and and I I feel umbrella yeah and I I do think
they uh like lost sight of her but for terms of
like an action movie where it was fun and I was
engaged throughout and had a little more on its
mind than I was expecting to uh I I thought it
was really good it pretty much gave me everything
that I wanted I think the first half is stronger
but there are some great stuff in the in the last
half yeah personally yeah yeah know not excuse me
yeah and I I I hear what you're saying and I
totally agree with you just like on in terms
of her character I get it she's an FBI agent you
got to tiptoe that line on you know your job and I
get it they did come around to it in the end where
you know she did let him go which I'm glad she did
um but yeah it did feel like it was more personal
to Jason Statham's character uh which again you
know we we found out like that uh the there was
that line of dialogue that how she was the only
one who was ever like you know that motherly
figure that was kind to him and understandable
but I I really would have uh you know just if when
they were leaning more on that serious stuff just
would have liked that they were showing like that
she was extremely conflicted with like trying to
you know do her job or take this more in a more
personal sense cuz I really feel like that would
have been a little more grounded in the sense of
all this but you know it is what it is um but also
too in in regards to Jason stm's character on top
of the badass that he was I just loved how you
know to your point as well in terms of like how
he was able to sneak into you know the the estate
and all that he was just so resourceful and you
know that came into whe whether he was sneaking
into places whether he had the tactical gear ready
to go um with the the suit or to go onto the beach
also too when he uh met the uh charismatic and uh
best character of the a partner FBI agent uh he's
like I have kids and he's like yeah three boys
and a girl and like he just he did his research
he was extremely uh you know uh just intelligent
he just knew things and I just I love intelligent
smart badass characters like that and I just was
so appreciative of that yeah I think I think this
was overall like a really this is a solid action
movie to me it's a solid action movie where um at
times I could like in the last half particular
there were certain scenes where I was like is
this when it was cheesy I felt like intentionally
self-aware yes and other times I'm like are we not
self-aware anymore and is this supposed to be like
really serious CU at times you're supposed to be
serious so you know and that's what I mean it's
fine you got to just find a balance though and I
think sometimes that balance comes a little bit
off and uh ese but whenever Jason STM is there
the movie is incredibly engaging and yeah for sure
I I really thought it it's fine that they didn't
but I truly thought they were going to go through
the entire film without him using a gun but the in
time that they did go that was incredible I mean
I can't remember the last time I saw an action
hero in it in this type of film go that long into
a film like with that many action sequences just
do hand toand no guns that was impressive yeah but
I think again that's a testament to David a as a
director uh is because the buildup to that you
know like you were really noticing sing it too
and I was noticing it so they Reserve when he uses
guns for a moment like they make it a moment when
he first uses that gun and even the introduction
like my favorite colorful villain play the last
guy who had the the the hallway fight with uh
because even the introduction on that guy like
he's so much larger than life he's so eccentric
and crazy but they set him up with the with the
um pratic leg prosthetic leg and that tells you
right away like you know this guy can take a hit
so take a lot of hits he could take a lot of hits
put a bullet in his face leg he's just going to
keep coming didn't care so there there is this
force of nature that just keep I me yeah that
guy had me saying this dude is a badass too he's
crazy yeah yeah uh I wonder if the there are any
fun facts here this is Jason stm's fifth film
in the last year that's it Adam Clay's birthday
oh this is a fun fact from the FBI file is July
2667 which is Jason stam's actual birthday you
didn't know that was his birthday oh I I didn't
either okay um this sounds like when Adam clay
EXC himself from the conversation with agent
Parker says I have to take care of the hive
this sounds like he is taking care of his bees
but instead the first reference to his former
world to protect Society that's so funny most of
this was shot in England really a lot of this oh F
fascinating I would have thought maybe they really
did shoot in Massachusetts no explanation of the
old Tech especially the CRT computer monitor seen
film is ever offered that because the story was
originally supposed to be said in 2003 remember I
was saying the computer I was like this is weird
the computers seem like they're older Tech yeah
uh before the idea was abandoned however as the
art Department had already started sourcing uh
some of the hardware for budgetary reasons it
decided just to keep in what they had already
purchased oh that's funny I don't know it kind
of like worked for me kind of like added to the
flavor of like they are so underground you know
uh that was that was that was really interesting
but no this was a fun fun movie Man uh I I really
liked it gave what I wanted keep scrolling down
there's I think there might be some more really
yeah keep going anything else oh no oh I thought
that okay I thought there was Nor they get more
facts when the movie's been while long forgot to
First St but yeah no overall good stuff um I hope
this movie is a lesson for the pieces of shits
out there that do these kinds of things and scam
people that if you ever do something like this an
actual beekeeper will come after you um so don't
even try it um I want to go to an actual beekeeper
and see what's up be like I know who you really
are beekeeper like um do you want some honey Craig
okay I don't know what you're trying to say here I
hope there are beekeepers out there who have
have a serious passion for their job who did
not see the trailer for this and saw oh beekeeper
finally a movie that does a story about beekeepers
I can't wait and then see they watch like this
is all my life like which organization do I need
to join this is a false representation of me as
in my profession now people who get scammed are
going to call me like this is not what I do I've
been asked to do a lot of things that are not part
of my what my job entails me to do now all righty
guys well good job David air awesome and Jason St
them what did you think of the beekeeper leave
your thoughts down below I think they can do a
sequel that goes and wall I would love a sequel
I really would I really love a sequel it's like
it's like an eight out of 10 for me yeah I
would say that too even two if they a sequel
I'd be down for even if they showed us a prequel
just what led him to getting to where we started
the film i' I'd be down for either or I'm just
so down for this universe The Beekeeper Universe
yeah I'm like 7.5 to 8 out of 10 somewhere there
where are you I'd probably go 7.8 out of 10 okay
yeah I'm like seven point if I'm going to look if
I'm looking for that solid so yeah 7. 797 damn it
oh beat me again yeah yeah anyway what do you
guys think leave your thoughts down below I had
a really fun time and I would absolutely love
a sequel we'll talk with you guys [Music] soon